hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast deep sequencing of the first
ten thousand human genomes I'm Judy
Oracle blab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab routes comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals before we start
there are a few instructions this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over and to get your credits
click on the CD button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
we wanna hear from you during this
interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment answers
welcome to you can do this by hitting
the green Q&A button the lower left of
the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions will try to
get to as many as we can on a better
look you can large Simon don't by
clicking on Serena icon in the lower
right hand corner of know if you can't
hear or see the presentation properly
let us know like the top right use the
Q&A button well sure we try to resolve
any issues I let's get right to today's
presenter we are got to Apollo's 28 PhD
dr 20 is ahead of no mixed fish and
longevity incorporated and research
science the Jake Red River Institute he
directs the team working on genetics and
genomics reason I thought cilenti led
the analysis of the ten thousand genomes
secret why he trained in internal
medicine and infectious diseases at Mayo
Clinic in Rochester Minnesota in
microbiology and genetics at the
university of bern switzerland and
albert einstein college of medicine in
bronx new york and after reagan
institute of mph and lucky and harvard
in boston between 2007 and 2014 was a
professor and director of the institute
of microbiology and in every song
switzerland doctors he has published
sensibly and save many national and
international awards queen dearest what
award the highest distinction in
medicine in Switzerland in 2012 elected
as a member of the swiss academy of
medical sciences in cannes acne
affiliations with the j craigs enter
into to determine medicine at university
of california san diego i will now turn
it over to dr. silenzio for his
presentation good morning infant duty
for introduction it is a pleasure to
present some of my work both dedicated
to enter institutes a academic
institution and also human charity which
is a corporate institution wetland
genomics hey today we are going to
discuss four topics one is the concept
of what do we mean when we refer to
sequencing a genome the second one is
the type of dimensions and aspects that
can be learned from studying a large
number of genomes in this case than
cotton genomes at what we call a deep
sequencing level some short aspects on
interpreting data in some examples and
then I as an application I will show the
impact of rare human variation on
genetics of response to viral infections
and here I mean things like a true or
other very common infections in the
population so on the first topic what's
a genome I give you hear the numbers
from the last 18 months of publications
of large-scale efforts to sequence human
genomes on the top is they they will
establish very well-known thousand
genomes project that was published in
2015 and as one of the most efficient of
publications
and then you see that we have all the
countries we have the African genome and
overall the total of published genomes
approaches fourteen hundred forty
thousand genomes in the public domain
now you have to pay attention to the
third column called average coverage
this is how many times in average we
have read this code it's like if you're
reading a book and you are asking how
many times you go through the hook to
make sure you got it right and you
memorize then you will not leave the
word or a chapter and you see there that
the average coverage varies profoundly
between some of these studies so some
people read a book for times like in
sylvania genomes some people read the
book 32 times like in the Japan genome
and you will see in a moment that this
makes an important difference and then
finally the last column talks about
number of bit coverage and here we are
referring to those that have higher than
20 X coverage in this published genomes
and there you see that actually the
number decreases to 2,400 so when we are
referring to a genome one of the
important thing is to understand what is
being referred to in terms of depth and
depth in sequence the genome quickly
translates into quality precision false
positives false negatives for
discovering rain so when we cover the
genome at great depth we obtain what you
see in the upper part of this slide
these are all the autosomal genomes and
you can see that I place a blue color
there were the deep situation of genome
riches and you see that actually
contract to the belief of some people we
never sequenced the genome completely
accepting related major effort and use
multiple techniques
when you just use the most commonly
available technique that is a short read
technique like a the one used by a
lumina you will have a difficulty to go
through all the complex parts of the
genomes and let those include like you
can see here for some work in a channel
14 I'm going to paint it out so you can
see here these two genomes have a
complete lack of sequencing on the
traumatic part and then we can put
another genome part right here where
typically you are looking at the
centromere is not easily sequence across
any one of the genome so you can see and
also the chromosomes have gray areas
around the central map which is known
because of repetitive sequences because
of what we call low complexity new
sequences so the first lesson is that
you have to read it on multiple times
for precision and also you have to read
the genomic great depth to try to cover
the most of your genome territory I put
on the bottom what is a equivalent for
exxon so when people say we have
sequence a the exome they are sequencing
of course 2 percent 1.5 to two percent
of the genome that corresponds to the
coding and you can see the amount of
information that is not being recorded
by extreme projects I don't take this
slide aspects such as a teletype in a
race I used in G wise analysis for like
using some commercial companies that
offer direct to consumer because
genetically arrays only canalize unique
positions between 500,000 and three
technical imputation several million and
of course it will not be even
represented at this hiatus scale so
summarize this sequencing a genome
requires for a maximal position
national coverage original requires
extensive depth and this has not been
here consistently reached by many of the
exxon projects again anything that is
not a full genome coverage of course as
you can see here and gives a minor on a
completion of the genome sequencing even
though for example situation deck song
can be extremely informative until the
protein called a areas when we sequence
this very large numbers of genomes can
we go to all the depth of course what
we're seeing is the true nature of
humiliation and what we obtain quickly
is this type of graphic worked in the
left we can see many millions in this
case 80 million variants that have seen
only once so thin tail and reflect about
this we look at a thousand people and we
already have 80 million of variance only
since once we are various scenes only
price three times four times etc and
only all the way to the right what it
says more than five percent and I'm
going to put an arrow right here this is
what is called common human variation
more than five percent allelic frequency
in the population basically when you are
genotyping with an array when you are a
genotyping elevator to consumer you are
looking only to the right two columns of
this crack the high percent possibly the
one percent to high percent and if you
do imputation that means that using what
is the others in its present around you
you can reach the earlier arrow that
means one to 0.1 percent of the
population so if you think about these
what we call common variants are
actually rare variants
and when you call rare variants the ones
that I've seen all these things seen
ones are extremely common and pray very
important for the future of discovery in
human genetics so let's summarize a bit
to give you a scale of the task ahead
what the genetics and genomics and
medical community will face our
fantastic challenge in the next coming
years I have represented here the amount
of variation that I have observed going
through now twenty thousand genomes at
him a longevity and this is the large
black circle I have observed 400 million
variants mostly because of variation the
next circle the red circle is the
content today of the public database gb
SSD that you produce that contains 184
million variants so it tells you that
already just by sequencing at great
depth twenty thousand genomes we are
basically already doubling the amount of
knowledge available in the poly database
now what is very impressive is when you
start getting to the center which slide
is that that blue circle is all the
coding variants known today and these
are deposited in exact at the Broad
Institute hey you can almost say that
the whole planet is today turning around
inside this blue circle that is we have
a tremendous interest and that's
appropriate on the calling diversity
humans but you also need to appreciate
that that's only part of the picture of
human diversity because it Dwarfs to see
this exact data in the midst of what has
been already observed in a blink coding
part of the hinge low and there is a
still
or you may not see that there is a pixel
right in the middle of the blue circle
that you may not actually even see that
is cleaner in one is the NIH supported
repository of clinical variants and they
contains around 100 hundred twenty
thousand variants it's a very important
tool but again we have to put it in the
perspective of exact you have to put it
in this perspective of all the human
variations that we are currently
identified and even be behind that pixel
there is something is true even less
than a pixel is that even with unclean
bar there are sets of variants that are
better known and better studied for
Mendelian disorders that's worry around
10 to 15,000 variants are really
carrying confidence signals with
agreement between laboratories and then
there is something coming from the g1's
that is a statistically confirmed even
though usually of a modest individual
impact that is the G was variants and
those are 16,000 also coming from public
repositories so recapping on this figure
we are making tremendous progress he
lets us associations with common
disorders million trades either from
Endymion there is a huge effort in the
community to try to 35 is knowledge into
cleaver there is a hitch effort trying
to cover a human variation in coding
regions and lead led by exactly there is
a main effort of recording all these
variants in public databases like dbsnp
but we are expanding the amount of in a
variation extremely rapidly and this is
going to be a very important challenge
for the community to understand their
meaning in human diversity trades and
decisions
where are all these variants coming from
there are many mechanisms of having so
many rare variants there is a founder
effect for communities there is ancestry
populations geographical variants and
him all the fin del Camino Jitsu human
evolution migration and all the
environmental selective pressures that
may lead to selecting and then
eventually fixing variation there is one
mechanism that is important is the
normal limitations and the door
mutations typically look like in this
graphic when we see a child with a nail
or fibromatosis this is a disorder and a
rare disorder and you can see a very
ugly green that is more or less fifty
percent of the bound files of the ribs
that's are the gray areas in the square
you see that the mother doesn't have
that green variant you see that the
father does not have that degree invalid
that typically is a de novo mutation
acquire head by two main mechanisms one
is in this case very early post
psychotics mutation of the embryo the
real possibility that this variant
exists has extremely minority variant in
the mother or in the father in a somatic
form that means that some cells in the
body vector illustration and it may be
transmitted head to the embryo during
the conception so this is an important
mechanism and pray any one of us carries
5202 de novo mutations and when we are
born and we're different from our
parents so this is a very important
motor of generating human diversity
human rare variants and then it is
evolutionary pressures that may lead to
some of these variants being a
successful some of them will be neutral
and some of them like in this case with
child will be the littles and may
compromise the fitness of the subject
that carries the mutation when we put
together all the rare variants observed
in this case is another study completed
that was published six months ago they
all 30,000 people and I asked the
question how many genes can be truncated
even though there is so many rare
variants and this will be the green line
on the left so the green line of the
left is the number of genes that I
observe to take it as we observe more
and more individuals and you can see
that the green light keeps increasing
and the yellow line are a subset of
those that are really particularly
severe to the gene that carries them
that mean that we expect that there will
be a profound damage to the protein what
you can say is that as we go on we will
observe over eighty percent of the human
genome and proteome can be observed in
summary as carrying a true nature of the
protein so it is like a human experiment
of seeing how many genes can we him
knock out at least one copy and still be
able to make a healthy or Widow not
healthy but a living adult and you can
see that we can knock out many genes at
least one of the two alleles and still
make it to eat life now what you
observed also towards the end of the
curve as we increase the number of
variants observed we do not which one
hundred percent that means yes there are
genes that will not be observed ever
with application even in the context of
heterocycles even in the context of
being only one of the two copies and
this is what we call the upload
insufficient genome that means DOJ's
that you need both competent on
copies to make a healthy adult or being
born so obviously this is showing you
that for many genes missing one copy
will probably lead to embryonic
lethality and not been observed in
another population the same data can be
observed in in children in engineering
minds you can also observe this
phenomenon of the ugly sufficient genome
and the fact that rare heterozygous
sensations may be bad enough to produce
embryonic lethality and there's no plant
examples of rare mutated the various
conceal disorders in adults so what can
we do ones that we have so much data and
I'm going to give a three examples you
can opt for profiling individual risk
and here would we friendly call the
wheel of fortune will be one individual
multiple trades menu then our medical
common traits and you can produce what
is called risk scores that these are
weighted or additive a discourse in
putting together common variation and
increasingly rare variants to calculate
the live your lives risk in a population
in this case this person for all the
trait that we are computing and that
goes from respiratory neurological or
even phenotypic traits you can see that
for the most part this person is I will
put an arrow is this person is for the
most part align to the average of the
population so it does not make a
particular in risk beyond the population
average risk let's say average risk for
plasma you can see other examples where
the person is high for some parameter in
this case is Sam
Prince potion to melanoma and in this
case this person has already had a
melanoma much of this risk is calculated
in this case from commonalities that
reflect on the quality of the skin in
terms of being failed and be more
susceptible to a UV light damage other
cases we do have this cone inherited
cancer risks that are alleles with a bit
more a medium impact on consular
disposition you can also see that the
special has some increase risk for
partisan and Alzheimer's and you can
observe on trades that this person can
also have some risk in terms of a trade
like bonus and this person is a
prematurely bald this profiling
individual risk is still very
controversial this is particularly
powerful that population level many of
the components are they coming from
large G what study and but increasingly
we are able to include rare variants and
therefore make even more individualized
predictions of particular risks another
genetic application that you can and you
will initially be seeing is the fact
that the genome is providing more and
more accurate informational traits in
this case I can present here the
prediction of a human face that includes
not only the parameters of the face the
nose we all serve them driven by
ancestry but also how you can estimate a
from the genome BMI and you can estimate
from the genome age and therefore there
are no tools that are being to give some
prediction in some predictive value for
forensics in terms of predicting the
person face and you will be for example
a the face that here in the middle if I
can put the hair oh well if you get that
that
phase actually we complete the face but
we can actually predict age and weight
from the genome and therefore products
produce a rendition of the face by an
artist by program that will try to
adjust the face frame to the also
genomically predicted h in BMI color
skin color hair color height daughter
also pretty well predicted and you can
complete a pretty interesting I will say
still not accurate but very interesting
prediction of an individual remains from
a an accident or from a terrorist attack
or from a furnace accuses you can reduce
important aspects of the people this of
course opens a whole new discussion of
the hostility or not to be identified
the genome where genomes are beginning
to be precise in terms of predicting and
biometrics and then you have to start
wondering whether the concert or the
identifying genomes will hold true for
log so the genomics is becoming a very
powerful generic biometric to now what
happens with rare variation saying I
already touched on it when I was
mentioning that one there are lots of
them in each one of us second they are
potentially new and therefore not tested
for fitness and third they may carry a
particular effect on a trade or a
disease at any time through h and this
can be also happen unless showed from
the upper surface and genomes and also
have it also from a heterozygous state
of some of the rare variations with
damaging effects so let's take an
example this is a real data from the cdc
that's a normal flu epidemic in this
case which 2009 and what was for me
very interesting was to compute the
lethality of this epidemic on children
and even though it's a normal shoe
epidemic you still find that thousand
two hundred eighty children died across
the United States and forth t % of dolls
or around 300 children were actually
theoretically fully healthy so you can
think of it in Mendelian terms and saved
9280 children out of 20 million that's a
one in 40,000 which is more or less a
pretty common frequency prevalence for
many rare disorders so you can ask a
completely fair question is something as
common as dying from through or having a
severe flu could this be a rare disorder
a manifestation of genetics and not just
like many people say well was bad luck
was a bad infection and the child I just
one gets tricky body in terms of
genetics can one in 40,000 represent
mutations and yes you have exactly the
scenario that we described a digital
level that either from the novel or from
rarity and medallion possibilities
obtained from father and mother you can
have events like in this child in this
case of a compound heterozygous is a
front rather from mother and I will put
an arrow right now so you can have from
mother from father a compound
heterozygous ease that will produce a
few damage to a particular important G
and pathway of response to a viral
infection at least eight different
pathway and with other colleagues we
have now began mapping many of the
children to all the genes in the
different pathway making true what is
stated in the prior hypothesis life that
means that
thing that is rare anything that happens
before the reproductive age or even
anything that shortens our lifespan even
as an adult can be analyzed under the
concept of a genetic basis even if it's
a common disorder given us no notion
ever he's been a Mendelian the fact the
observation and the novel possibilities
of creating human variants some of which
are profoundly damaging have to be
considered as self fair hypothesis to
pursuit so again think genomics when you
observe something that happens to a
child before reproductive age or
something thats happening tonight that
will shorten the effective lifespan of a
human being and the effective lifespan
of a human being now is somewhere
between 80 and 90 years old so dine at
40 years old from even a common disorder
you can prepare prepare and close the
fair question of is the genetic is
having a tumor a cancer at four years
old if the genetic and there is a good
possibility that there will be a genetic
basis for an unexpected event then I
want to complete the next step and 57
minutes on another example of what it
means to investigate very rare variation
in humans and in this case I'm going to
put not so much an epidemiological
example but I'm going to show you a
functional example of how we are going
to go through these observations of
human diversity in its structure ality
so here we have a particular cell
cigarette excel and you can see that
there are green dots I'm going to put a
arrow there green dots right there in
the middle those are a viral particles
being concentrated and by the synthetic
cell to do an important function that is
a cross presentation that in the
dendritic cell will exhibit and present
these viral particles to have cd4 cd8
line and set okay so let's have an
example when you go through a database
you find that there are a fair number of
humans it's a very rare variant that you
have tram number of humans that have
very early stop in this protein called
select one and this is indicated there
by the stop sign I'm going to market so
many humans not many humans some humans
about one every two thousand we have
homo psychosis for this particular scene
like one obviously they are alive
obviously they are for the most part
healthy and you can find them in exactly
you can find in any repository at times
because this is not collected by
genotyping erase this has to be
specifically sequenced to be observed
but the fact is that there are humans
walking around we have the g so those
that work in the antiviral and the viral
pathogenesis fail were surprised to
learn that this important protein that
exerts this feature of capturing and
cross presenting these viruses to the
new system they were surprised that this
person could be a existing without this
particular a innate immunity protein
okay so let's move to next slide
so the first question was is this true
do these people really like this
particular function and here on the
panel to the left I'm going to market
you can see that's the density of this
protein the surface of people with a
frequent elite the commonality this is
in heterocycles and this would be in
homozygous so what you can see is that
there is no doubt people that are alive
with the temptation of cyclic one they
don't have this protein the surface
there is no a compensation possible and
even heterozygous are up insufficient
that means they have less protein than
the common Ali so this protein exists
this protein is functionally missing
when the restaurant Asian and then we go
to the biological assays and you can see
that anything that it is not going to
market again any particular parameter or
function will be a damaged cast you try
to do functional assays and with viruses
in this case is a type of virus is based
on both and HIV in what is called blp
that means is covered with an envelope
from another virus and what you can see
is this drug from that blue to blue the
light blue that means that the person
that has a signet one rotation has no
signal in the surface and this function
cannot be supplemented by anybody else
effectively the dendritic cell loses the
possibility to attract these virus
induces the possibility to bring this
virus to that actual immune system so
once that this is done you can and you
will be persuaded persuaded that people
with this particular allele will suffer
for example HIV infection the ax virus
differently because you are seeing that
the function has been clearly lost now
is that true
and when you go to the actual biology
and that we have said that means that we
lose signal we lose the facility to to
trap and pass it sells to the CB force
and actually when we log go to beat
databases of HIV infected people we find
that there are homozygous people that
are infected and I'm going to mark them
here webster's people that are infected
even though they block the gene there
are people here heterozygous and
homozygous they progress through disease
this is the typical evolution of an HIV
person a progression few years and
decreasing what is called the cd4 t-cell
count that means the cell that started
by the viruses and you can see that
there is no difference between the
evolution of people who are heterozygous
they are no difference in the difference
of the positive the rocking perform
disease on the homozygous here are
beyond us only two people and also
against the population a average
installation no evidence that the HIV
infected population has any modification
of the allele frequencies implying that
it would be protected from they acquire
the infection and or that there will be
any presence of a depletion a particular
truncated homozygosity in operation so
summarizing is a slide means that even
though the temptation exists in all if
individuals even though the truncation
really impairs the presentation of this
protein in the high approp itself in
delta t cells even though the cell
stopped dropping the viruses and
presenting a tune in a community system
that does not mean that in vivo that
function is relevant and here's where we
start saying the biology eat in the true
in vivo a setting where wherever we
think we test in vitro still we have to
be
confronted with genomic data and I think
this opens people here where to tensions
will be or damaging variance will have
to be assessed not only in vitro
functionally but you have to be assessed
at population level to really measure
whether in vitro data truly translates
into in vivo effects so I have two more
slides and I will be stopping my part so
you can make questions one is that the
example I showed for a influenza the
example I showed for HIV and you can go
ahead with many many other presentations
like representing this and particular
panel of like thousand individuals and
all those names on the top now we're
going to mark them like here all these
names are many viruses that affect the
population and you see that we have
examples of truncated a severe completed
a pro teens for jeans that are
understood to be critically important
for the containment of these viruses at
least in vitro and I'm of course very
excited to see that some of these
viruses and some of these gene
confrontations will be analyzed at
population level to understand whether
the in vitro evaluation of these
proteins these truncations with
translate or not on population effects
like the one we saw with the child that
got severe a flu from a particular
mutation so we have many many candidates
in the population and around you many
people will be carrying particular
variants that will potentially put them
at risk during childhood and in
adulthood in embryogenesis and for a bad
outcome so i'm concluding there and this
will be the summary of my presentation
the fact that we are now sequencing
thousands of individuals is opening the
door to understanding the extent of
human endogenous ease by now we have
observed one every eight position in the
genome has been observed by now variant
and so retain that number one every
eight position in the genome has already
been observed variant in sign individual
usually through rare variants so a large
proportion of all imaginative areas
discovered and to be discovered is
individually rare maybe you are the only
person that has a variant but
collectively there is millions and
millions of rare variants now being
identified across 18 Angela as extreme
example of this we have now examples of
human nulls and heterozygous mutations
and therefore the potential for up
insufficiency or large proportion of
genes in the genome and the current
count is that right eighty to ninety
percent of the genes in the genome have
been observed at least in heterozygous
education and therefore the facility for
a gene does affect apples efficiency
negative dominant effects there are many
ways that it related heterozygosity I
can do functional damage and I put as
examples severe diseases that follow
either common infections or other common
diseases and you have to be attentive to
think and push the genetic hypothesis
meaning that as I mentioned earlier the
normal thing should be for a child to
which reproduction and from an adult to
reach full species say H that means 80
to 90 years old anything that
dramatically shortens either your
childhood or shortens your current life
can be in fair terms they ascribe to the
possible genetic defect because the
material genetics abstract for such
watery such possibilities exist and we
are now looking at it as we go through
these large amounts of the genomes I
want to conclude there and I'm happy to
initiate a the kernel of questions and
answers and I'm passing the microphone
back to Julie excellent presentation dr.
Valente thanks for bringing that
information to us before we get started
with all of your questions here's a
quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will get to as
many as we can and our first question
comes from Tammy she asks with respect
to variants on exons is it known the
extent to which this impacts certain
allele frequencies for certain genes so
thanks Tammy and of course and again
several ways to answer to your question
one is all exons are subject of the same
pattern of rare and common variation
that I described at a genome level and
if you go to the exact database you do
the same calculation you will see that I
think one every eight a position in
exomes has been already Oxford with a
variant now the place in the exon will
of course modify profoundly the allelic
frequency because there are periods like
a splice acceptor splice donor working
domains that are critical that will be
extremely resilient talking a variation
when we go not through a larger scale
computing of the distribution of
variance you will clearly see the
pattern of places were a the exomes will
be except from variation at some sites
all across the genome so not only we
have served genes that may or may not be
truncated we also know across all
proteins the position that are uniquely
protected from any particular damage
particularly splice acceptor on all
sites I hope that answers your voice
James asks could all variants be placed
into the context of energy sorry in on
one second sorry about that jumped
around while there could all variants be
placed into the context of energy energy
dependent changes in hydrogen atom
transfer into DNA base pairs in solution
and virus driven energy theft which
causes mutations so thank James for this
question I think to be honest I think we
have to see every base pair change and
its consequences in this case you are
citing and interaction with the virus a
very much in the biology of function of
what is being happened I don't think
that summarizing all interactions on
energy dependent interactions will be an
appropriate for all mechanisms it can
certainly appropriate for contact
dependent interactions for example sun
face interaction with receptors from
viruses all viruses to largest and use
human surface proteins for entry into
cells and they are of course very
susceptible to a energy modification
because this up the hydrophobic forces
are part of the early contacts between
cells
but once that you are at other levels
interaction with a wrist what we call in
terminologies or anything will depend on
many other mechanisms that go beyond
purely physical and leather is like the
one you described right back to UT Zara
asks which tool do you use for profiling
individual risk so thanks to Sara and
there is a lot of interesting how do we
compound and compute on more than one
allele and the what is called the
genetic risk scores like the one we use
our represent an approximation that is
probably not fully satisfactory to to
all of us of completing multiple alleles
so think about the system where a
particularly has been calibrated in a
large population under thousand people
and you have an odds ratio at risk ratio
a better score from your logistic
analysis that gives your value and this
value may not necessarily be large for
example a alteration 1.2 represents a
twenty percent increase in risk that
same person may at the same time carry a
protective allium with a point eight
odds ratio and therefore the completed
risk for this person will be simply
point eight a I will add it to 1.2 and
we give a neutral a risk for this person
you can imagine that this is a amazing a
simplification of the problem but to be
honest all the community is using this
type of simple positive or weighted
additive and approaches to completely
multiple alleles can it works if you
compute height height can be completed
from 600 genetic variants and you get a
pretty good approximation to hide
provide something like five six
centimeters differences and precision so
it works but is pray for those that will
have a mathematics that is exploiting
not very satisfactory but to Judy okay
James asks in substitutions near the
receptor binding site determine major
antigenic change during influenza virus
evolution the authors claim that the
major antigenic changes of the influenza
virus are primarily caused by a single
amino acid near the receptor binding
site you agree so Jamie internet so any
interaction again I think we go back to
the prior question we discuss yes a
surface interactions between receptors
and viruses are extremely susceptible to
mutual variation that develops through
human coevolution with pathogens in the
sched balances were the virus
establishes a avoidance strategy making
mutations in the virus and eventually
the human being will have to fixate
figural are favorable alleles to
counter-attack a particular weakness of
the entry side a this is referred in the
evolutionary bitter chiral day with red
queen effect and it is the constant to
and fro interaction between pathogens
and human that force variance in both
the host and the pathogen so it's not
one side or the other both of them will
go through a cycle of fixation a
mutation to achieve the equilibrium
this ongoing interaction marketing manju
asks which deficiency causes information
in hearings so thanks man G M you are
asking a right question there is a an
estimated depending on conservative
estimate or or growth estimates there is
four hundred two thousand four hundred
genes that are label innate immunity in
the human variants in subset of those
are extremely well known to cause the
Mendelian disorders a common variance in
many of dogs are well known to produce a
set ability to more common disorders
including things like Crohn's disease
psoriasis rheumatoid arthritis a silly
apiece disease so the question you're
asked is absolutely correct but it's
extremely broad it means every one of
the four hundred or thousand four
hundred genes depending how you crowd
can be observed variant and many of
those are being marked to a specific
inflammatory disorders and in many cases
these are really gene-specific so you
may just knock out one particular gene
from interfering response and you will
only suffer a deficiency towards a
particular pathogen or you may change a
particular set of innate immunity genes
through common variants and you will
have a discrete increase in risk of
Crohn's disease or of arthritis and not
all the reformatory diseases so it is
really a huge diversity of genes
producing organ diversity of syndromes
back to Julie
Helen asks what methods are you using to
look at the contribution of rare
variants of small effect two common
human disease so Helen you are putting
their the finger in a in a difficult
place yes we are looking at particular
models one typical model that works in
sex is like for example mopping
metabolome metabolic changes a metabolic
change is typically map well to to the
genes even through common variant
analysis and within those Manhattan plot
type associations at that area of
association on the genome we can Antef I
multiple rare variants they tend to have
stronger effects so they add potentially
powerfully to any score but what we are
not frequently confronted is on sons of
rares so it typically ten individual
with one rare variant may not carry a
second rare variant either to alleviate
or to increase even further the
mechanism when that happens we may go
directly into real medallion disorders
through compound hit compound
heterozygous its mechanisms of a dual a
rare variant effects but a it is a very
exciting thing and if you look at the
literature that is now we are effort to
try to to push in the two models common
variants evil low common variants one
percent to five percent and rare
variants in two and more personalized
prediction buckle Judy
olap ave asks how many of these gene
defects can be associated with
environmental influences especially
toxic environments Alabama this is a
very correct question and and let's go
back to one of their models I presented
when I say well you may be 40 years old
and suffer from a cancer and premature
cancer a there is an already evidence
for some moments where of course if you
have a particular variant in a
detoxifying a pathway if you have a
particular variant in the DNA repair and
it is typical for many of the cancer
predisposition jeans and when you like
Lynch syndrome where you damage the
mekinese of integrity of the genome any
environmental influence will make all a
unchecked and that's where you may have
a very important convergence between
environment and damage and genetic
damage where we can see that those two
are together not just here individual
effects on already so you can say that
yes you may have to smoke to have lung
cancer but you can also say that
particular and damages to your genome
correcting for DNA damage correcting for
detoxifying effects will compound and
increase the effective environmental
toxic back to drilling kavita asks are
we thinking in terms of snv pathogenesis
within jeans so that we can find this on
your question you are asking about
single nucleotide variants pathogenesis
and I hoped I understand where your
question a of course there is seeing a
look at the variation that we are
beginning to understand better a huge
effort on all other forms of genetic
variant a typical individual with 34
million single nucleotide variants and
maybe 200,000 very small indels a 12
basis and then we will have some
hundreds thousands of larger structural
variation some copy number variations
and some other forms of modification
genome now the reason I don't make
currently too much emphasis is because
there is still some precision issues on
calling correctly copy number variation
and there is a huge interest of trying
to get better colors of a structural
variation copy number variation other
forms of diversity to analyze them in
the context or game of trades and this
is of course there are many medical
examples a of all these things cost
analysis and only issue here is that the
purely short read driven Shalom
sequencing has some limitations in
precision when calling a popular
variation in structural variations but
to Julie Tammy asks
is their genetic redundancy of genes
that are found to be null in some
individuals and are these found in
certain biological pathways are these
only jeans found only genes that
function in immunity so thanks Tammy and
your question is very appropriate and I
think all of you are well knowledgeable
in the fact that there is same gene
families there is a gene duplications
there is things or item the cytochromes
where you have multiple times genes that
are all a bit similar and therefore they
say intense an important substrate in
the human genome for a redundancy there
is a lot of debate here whether we have
pure redundancy that means another gene
can take over the loss function of gene
that has been lost or whether it is
robustness that means that the network
is able to accommodate the loss of one
of the leads members and there are
models for both systems some of the
things I've showed to you into the
updates efficiency taught us that many
of the approach efficiency event will
not be compensated in terms of the gene
catching up to the appropriate levels of
expression through the one single left
over copy so we know that there is a lot
of a capacity of the network to be
robust and we are in some ways less
convinced that you can speak about pure
redundancy where another protein another
allele takes full compensation of the
defect through the same pathway so I
hope that answers and of course this is
beyond immunity immunity any or the any
system really lacks egg it has this
property of a robustness through a
redundancy and compensation and rope
later writers of the network 2gb can we
have time for one last questions from
bill what do you mean by collectively
prevalent are you referring to the
variant or the individual so bill thanks
for the clarification yes and so if you
have handled individuals then everybody
has one rare variant you can say every
single individual has a rare variant and
therefore we turn that electrically
prevalent not individually rare so
they're very enticing the same one
collectively everybody scurrying rare
variants or I think it's just to
misspell they doubt that people say
where rare variant something that
happened rare in the population rare
variants happen as a unit really
population but rare variants are
extremely calm because everybody has
tons of rare variants that would means
collectively prevalent it back to juvie
I would like to once again thank dr. 24
his presentation do you have any final
comments no yes thank all the organizers
this is a great opportunity to present
our work and I'm really very impressed
by the number of questions and interest
and in the follow-up of these at forum
thank you very much again
thank you this is an educational webinar
on das offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over and to
get your CD credits click on the CD
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through November 12 2016 you'll receive
an email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on lab
routes comm you're welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time